They said I was too pretty to fight.
She can't fight.
You're gonna mess up that beautiful face.
They said I was too fat.
They said my nose was too prominent.
They said I was too masculine.
They thought that catcalling was a compliment.
He said, "You can fix those teeth quite easily."
Boyish and ugly.
When they were talking about "female," they weren't talking about me.
This was not pretty.
They would holler from across the street.
Look sophisticated.
Embarrassing nose.
Too chubby.
Was too skinny.
Manly.
Crazy hair.
Never look good.
Too wild.
Too cute.
Too beautiful.
Too fat.
He said.
They said.
She said.
I said, "No way!"
You aren't me. I'm me.
I'm not gonna be defined by anyone's expectations.
I don't dress my age.
I dress myself the way I am.
'Cause my face has nothing to do with my boxing.
I'm ranked number one in the country and number two in the world.
As a fashion blogger, my style is 100% unapologetic.
I don't wanna change my teeth.
This is me.
This is my hair.
My beauty.
My say.